l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono pro vj oggi siamo tornati con
ciccio e pietro su raft razza sembra che
dica rast però con la r s moscia
questa volta proviamo a fare il
ricevitore per trovare la terraferma
buona visione
ma è sulla punta verso la punta occhi
uno squalo dietro il mio abbellimento e
stato bellissimo vedersi cambiare
direzione
guardano già ricostruita che volete
grazie all'orario riconferma razzi l'ala
non si può non si muove per niente alla
z come mai aspetta per un po che gliene
anch'io
ok ma più a destra per un po bedeschi
certo ma chi avrà avrà adesso dritto
dritto dritto e un po scomoda strada
delle isole dovremmo fare una scala da
300 hanno però si sa basta ampliare il
piano di sopra realta ci siamo girati
ragazzino si muove troppo la pro am ai
baci con trovarci contro ci contano
andavo da parte di andarci contro vai
dritto dritto pagare ogni volta ne
nostra ds misura è un parto paparazzi
giustamente ci abbiamo una portaerei
pagaiare un po un casino
ok ma eccoli manico si sa ma c'è una
roccia cavolo niente abort mission di
sopra un sacco di lottare per ora grande
porta li portano perché non è questo qua
vicina ma perché non c'è l'isola sporca
butta paga adesso no
no c'è che ti prego insomma rendere poi
ottimo sopra provato a ad accettare la
palma si scemo
roma e non fa niente non le 20 anni e
bella da vedersi lascia lì ma questa
voce la in fondo ragazzi e gesù è vero
roba lì c'è una luce nel cielo cioè ci
sia gente qua dritto davanti a nasce una
luce sopra sopra
no solo gli eletti possono vederla ma ce
ne sono altri ma sono stelle [ __ ]
di scemi o mio dio da è legato glielo
siamo gli eletti ma io ci c'è qualcosa
di un cenno stelle non c'è bisogno di
dire in giro che non sia questo del
cuore ci crediamo comunque mangiate come
dei ma per nota si sta allagando con
eletto no però
totti buonanotte amici pesci buonanotte
dormi come vai sapevo di di alga marina
quando mi sono svegliata
adesso sa posso credo la cosa sapore di
cozze
ma che bella primo cantiere ai ragazzi
stava morendo di ampliare nessun
bloccato allora tu fai il piano di sopra
e io penso a fare l'antenna questo
episodio antenna e ok schietti e vecchi
odi e rottami di veggiato tutorial di
come fare ricevitrice vi abbiamo 800
progetti uguali dell'eterna ok come lo
creo me lo dici quello credo che mi
aspetto che proprio a google arno lario
quattro oggetti che ve li dico 8 assi se
in plastica un cardine un circuito di
bordo si chiama riserve dei chopper nel
copper non chopper shopper
io parlo come voglio antenna come si
dice a mantenere inglese si dice antenna
raf pole to build to build en antenna
esatto chi dice bill dann ten arata la
fa vedere come si così c'è quella reale
ecco antenna raft wiki quella reale si
dice che nella storia daisy ma come
servono dei circuiti madre per fare
circuiti matrici di legno per far elena
bono abbiamo missione troviamo arrivare
qualcosa fa qualcosa per certo la fama
fa qualcosa lega e si sbaglia
guarda che deficente guardalo grazie a
dei chiodi gli ha fatto tutti di
scolarsi circuito madre ricevitore
troppe ragazze avete dei chiodi fanno
dio fermi fiore di gemina parati dure
nalga l'alga petto
aspetta aspetta quella drogato scemo
impazzito e allora ok fermi zittisce
come hai fatto le pivot si potevano fare
le pinne in questo gioco o che era pre
che a me per fare il sopra mi
servirebbero dei chiodi è che i chiodi
sono impossibile trovare migliore la mia
cucina non si tocca al giovane pregava
fatto un calendario nudo
col cavolo che andare che cazzo server
guarda cosa guardare senza o miedeco
vinte giorni senza che figata che figo
super carino te non trovò la famiglia
ecc
non c'era l'acqua grazie allora è stato
e non la nazionale brava vederlo a posto
ma cosa io metto sempre l'acqua due mesi
si sia a posto tutte così dicono guarda
ha fatto una mano fa luce o la lanterna
che non fa luce non fa luce guarda le
mettere a cosa ha detto sì ma no perché
il giorno il giorno e giorno se cade
siamo nella cacca tutti quanti e te lo
dico non so se messi ma la reazione
isola sia lodato il cielo dormiamo vi
prego spagnoli 28 ott di oggi dormendo
priva di voi il money in people
ok qualcuno che me la so proprio io non
ho ancora fatto
sarà quella la signora 18
basta che c'è gloria la banda o abbiamo
tre scale c'è una sinistra una centrale
e noi cerchiamo destra lì era l'isola ne
poteva portarla tipo lo sta per fare
l'antenna qua mi serve tuo scioperino
ciccio erano achara ma eccolo quadro
puntato anch'io
e allora adesso che ho il rame neo 6 nei
dati un botto dovrei riuscire a creare
una copertina bacerò il mattone fresca
no mattone secco dove la sua mattone
fresco a me serve mattone secco
ecco forse dalla forma cioè che la
fornace per creare la fornace mi sarei
matto secco
chicca veloce quindi devo aspettare che
il mattone secchi per creare un
ricevitore ok
eccoli trecco l'isola sto dicendo ci
dobbiamo avvicinare un'isola ecco
l'isola ti va di canticchiare l'ingiusto
nostro per i nostri iscritti che ci
stanno seguendo
sei tu vieni qua non si sentiva la
english e luca bove chi ha remato jesus
christ in garal stopper che sei araba ma
mi piaci comunque
[Musica]
[Applauso]
in tutto il resto si era arrivati a
toccare e non so perché sei araba prima
sulla playlist di spotify adesso l'isola
let's go e aspetto devo mangiare ma
facciamo una bella roba [ __ ]
facciamo una scala li fa gravissimo
perfetto chi passa talmente tanto tempo
ogni volta che non mi ricordo perché mi
serviva così tanto andare sull'isola
l'acqua è diventato ormai un optional
cazzo ragazzi miei
mettete la prossima volta l'acqua in
quel cazzo di bicchiere bohemian acqua
perché non metti la con quel cazzo di
bicchiere perché nome di là che drogati
che si ebbe best cover qui i never ma
essicca qualcosa non è secca questo non
mi serve per fare ricevitore saper fare
la fornace che serve per fondere il top
perché al mercato mio padre comprato ma
36 conta è secco mio grato a destra di
sola andata all'isola io faccio il mio
ricevitore fondi striscia 6 mattoni si
trovano i mattoni secchi o una zattera
dove c'è zattera cesena dove ci sarà c'è
sabbia e argilla dove c'è saper girare
ci sono mattoni prescrive cinema temi
freschi c'è fonderia che bello per
entrare dentro una vi entrò il neretino
a non devi entrare dentro proprio allora
abbiamo il coso per fare i salti quindi
sassi mattoni freschi
3 e 4 amen oh mio dio
perfetto adesso sopra dove sono i sassi
che sono e che erano sopra questo se ne
deve andare questo ma gli
spaventapasseri attirato un passero a
cosa servono allora non ho capito
questi sono i soldi per fare la fonderia
123456 che però sono già essiccate
quindi questi devono essiccare poi posso
fare la fonderia e dopo la fonderia
possiamo fare questa benedetti anzi non
l'antenna ma il ricevitore che sta qui
va bè ragazzi si è messo a piovere
quindi con la faccia di sta cippa che si
essiccano distanza ci sono più bagnati
le prima però appena mi sia sicano
quelli o se i mattoni secchi che sono
quelli che servono per fare la fornace
che sta qua dove che sa la fornace con
editrice scusatemi e poi una volta che
ho creato la fondatrice possiamo fondere
il rame e mancherà un niente per fare
madonna quanto sia imbarcando acqua
maker o niente per fare il ricevitore
per poi trovare la terraferma che
speriamo esista ma credo di sì perché
del ricevitore porta esattamente a
quella quindi ragazzi però i video vi
sia piaciuto a qualsiasi di proceno 100
mi piace anche ai soci nella sessione
sono iniziati ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]